there was a few things that were really
garnering my interest as biosynthesis of
cannabinoids with super-interesting like
making miners can have a no it's more
prevalent by finding alternative lipids
or and I was really cool stuff water
solubility or or stability like making
infused beverage it's like I just known
beverage is going to be a huge category
yeah and finding the secret to do it and
he grabs a glass of water
dump it in and just like this versus and
clear I tasted it you know it was fairly
innocuous yeah and like I just wanted
straight tunnel-visioned at that point
like there could have been no one else
in the room we don't believe in in the
one-size-fits-all you know label for
this particular technology it's actually
a very complicated chemistry yeah we
approach each SKU with each new customer
completely differently and we ask them
you know what are you trying to deliver
to your consumer what's the experience
that you want them to have the mouthfeel
of taste and and beverage has been super
interesting like we could literally
infuse anything that has water but we
love beverage because it is actually
truly a new experience it's a new way to
absorb the cannabinoid you can be very
complex it's perceived to be a lot
healthier since you're not smoking or
vaporizing we've seen 60 and 70 year old
women trying cannabis for the very first
time having a very beautiful experience
and coming back raving about it all
their friends we've had people give us
really incredible testimonials on the
medical applications like literally a
woman living in pain for 20 years with
fibromyalgia you know having one little
vial 5 milligrams of THC
all of a sudden sleeping through the
night
shameless you know it's just it's really
special work you know we could do this
every day and and this is the real
exciting thing for me is beverage is a
great format to really experiment with
you know what is commonly called the
entourage effect but when people use the
entourage effect in cannabis they're
usually talking about the various
cannabinoids intervenes in the plant
entourage can go well beyond it like how
does CBD and THC interact with caffeine
or LP anymore octopanda
right it's like really diving into kind
of a broader plant science and
understanding like the different types
of experiences we create what we're
actually doing is creating these little
vehicles that you can put oil inside
that are friendly with water and it's
more of a suspension system but the the
science that we do makes it so that that
completely homogenizes and stays stable
over time this is the value that we're
creating right now our our customers
come to us and they say you know we want
to put THC CBD this full spectrum
spectrum extraction into a beverage it's
like okay we can help you do that we can
figure out the right emotions and stuff
the future is understanding how to
control the experience right and so so
right now we're letting our customers be
the creative ones someone's opinion me
contradict yours what is my friend Alan
it's all about your perspective who are
we and what is the nature of this
reality
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan Sathyan we are on
site at the beautiful new West Summit
the cannabis tech conference we are now
going to be speaking with Ben Larson
Thank You Alan
hi better to be here thanks so much for
coming on our show my comfiest it's been
a long time in the making it has yeah
I've gone through many lifetimes since
meeting you likewise hi guys damn yeah
it has an it's great both you know being
a part of founder Institute as well and
also you yourself starting a gateway the
premiere can of a startup accelerator
and now being the CEO Verto so and I'm
so pumped to jump into this because the
infusion of our products our beverages
and just products that larger is gonna
be a massive part of how we educate and
on board and all different types of
stuff so then let's jump into things on
a you know on a journey perspective you
know you found yourself you know being
born into this world how did you
identify you know what your North Star
is and what how you ended up pursuing
that yeah it's a great question it's
been a little bit of a circuitous route
you know growing up I was always sewing
that had a lot of ideas for any like I
just constantly I was that kid that was
sitting in the backseat of the car
saying hey mom wouldn't it be great if
we had a coffee machine that would wake
up before you and cook your coffee for
you
and it's like well you know that clearly
exists now but it was just I never had
the opportunity to like really take
these ideas to fruition or maybe I just
didn't have the knowledge of how to do
it and so you know circuitous route I
actually ended up going to school for
for engineering when I actually wanted
to be an architect I took way too many
classes ended up having to having to
graduate at a certain point and enter
the world of a professional engineering
but being in the Bay Area you're just
around so many inspiring people actually
creating things that are touching
people's lives
and I just fell in love with it so at a
certain point I just quit engineering
got right into it and you know from my
very first startup everything that I've
done has been about helping people
realize their their ideas and their
dreams and so that what eventually took
me to founder Institute
you know the skills that I picked up
working with startups all around the
world learning how to build startup
ecosystems that's what took me into the
cannabis industry it wasn't about a love
of the plant it is now but you know what
took me into that this industry was you
know people doing what they love and
care about and risking everything to do
so and at the time this was back in 2015
I saw a lot of capital trying to come to
the space and there was just this big
disconnect and in the tech industry
that's what we learned you know that's
why I startup incubator startup
accelerators are created to to bridge
that gap between these very passionate
you know smart entrepreneurs and the
capitalists that were looking to kind of
help build this industry and that was
kind of the Nexus of gateway and we the
cannabis bug come in though yeah it kind
of just found me you know I was asked to
mentor coach and judge some startup
competitions purely focused on the
cannabis industry this is a you know
very very bay area phenomenon right like
back in 2015 people pitching cannabis
companies I could probably count on two
hands the number of times I had consumed
cannabis before that but is very
eye-opening and it felt very much like
the early days of tech we just had this
this raw talent and and passion and it
doesn't need a little bit of guidance
thank you and so a 30-minute session
with the founder pitching their company
could phenomenally change their pitch to
be more appealable to investors or to be
more on the right path of creating a
commercializable product and so that was
the opportunity right like I my partner
and I at the time we had been asked to
help evaluate early-stage deal flow for
a fund that had been created for the
industry and after looking at it was
just like well you're having problems
because you don't have really
true deal flow you need to be able to
compare these two the same investment
opportunities that are in the tech
industry right and so that was the
vision coming into the industry it's
like we need to take all this raw talent
and and make it more appealing to the
mainstream and and raise the bar and so
you know that's what we did that's what
I continued to do today with Verto so
you know we're working with great brands
we're trying to create consistent
products that really appeal to the
mainstream and make it repeatable so
that it's scalable and so it's it's
always about asking the right questions
it's like you know and we learn this in
start-up worlds like what are you trying
to deliver to your consumer like always
make it about the consumer and
especially as an emerging market as an
emerging category this is very important
stuff right we need to know who we're
serving and we need to learn how to
speak to them educate them and bring
them along with the journey yes yes this
idea that your ability to compress your
Northstar down into an elevator pitch
can then catalyze your ability to fund
your North Star projects at greater
efficacies and also sell your North Star
projects along the just journey as well
it's just a compression algorithm can
you figure out how to do well enough can
you write it down a thousand times can
you really just continue synthesizing
and distilling over and over and over
again and also then can you have someone
that has experience like you review it
and then that way they can give you
feedback and then if in 2015 when you're
seeing you know cannabis pitches if
those got refined better and better you
can catalyze the emerging market rising
faster by giving a feedback look I mean
there's there's a lot of things at play
here and and everyone used to be at the
mindset it's like oh that's pretty good
for a cannabis company and we're like no
no it needs to be as good but better
than every other company out there
because not only do we have to make
something that is actually truly
scalable and actually invest of all but
we have to earn the trust of the
regulator's of
the general community right there there
should be no room for people to like
poke holes in your business because you
need to withstand all these external
pressures and that has been the hardest
thing in this industry it's it's hard
enough to build a business it's
extremely hard to build a business in a
shifting regulatory landscape
yes something that is questionably
illegal depending on who you ask and you
know there's there's just so much to
learn and we deal with a lot of new
entrepreneurs in space maybe it's their
first time building a company in this
space yeah so it is phenomenally hard
like much credit goes to those that are
that are actually trying to do it
because they are pioneers and they are
taking a lot of the bolt it's you know
as far as like just trying to do the
learning and you know what it comes back
to something that we preach a lot in in
the founder Institute is you really have
to have a strong why like why are you
here what is your North Star Yeah right
and for me it is seeing these hurdles
and helping people navigate them and
truly realizing the dream that's in
their head yeah in their heart yes right
yeah I love that I love that then so
then that that led to Gateway and then
Gateway was how many years how many
companies went through gateway right so
over three years we had 20 companies
come through the investment portfolio
and we would work you know day and night
six months straight with these companies
and and even beyond after kicking them
out of the office but entering the
industry when we did 2015 in Oakland
which was the kind of the birthplace of
the advocacy movement 215 all that kind
of stuff you know we kind of had a
cultural center and we opened up our
doors to the community we had a lot of
events we we hosted normal and and women
that grow and all this kind of stuff and
we actually ended up having a co-working
space which you know also berth quite a
few companies and you know our goal with
gate wave was to eventually kind of work
ourselves out of a job right we didn't
want the co-working space too
necessary anymore and as the years went
on you know more and more people went
and worked out we works in other
people's offices and there was the
community that was becoming more and
more public and less ashamed about what
they were doing mmm there was definitely
times where you know we've both been out
run way over over here in San Francisco
where I think cannabis companies were
very hesitant to kind of like be out in
the open there there's one that I can
really think of it was called weed club
that's actually weed club was how I came
into the industry they were doing these
pitch events I always thought it was
funny that like oh they chose weed and
just like lean right into it but you
know they put it out there and I'm like
oh there's actually weed businesses like
trying trying to build in this world you
know now we can work just about anywhere
in the Bay Area and it feels very
natural and that feels great to me
know we we were able to take a heavily
kind of like siloed you know the
zero-sum game kind of mentality and turn
it inside out and have this culture of
sharing and a rising tide and that feels
really great you know we have a really
strong community and it's all about
helping each other succeed because like
I said you know has it been easy
2018 you would expect with legalization
that we would all been really excited
about it
but it's been a really tough year there
was a purge of small businesses because
you know even though there's a lot a lot
of lip service paid to them like we want
to help small business California about
small business you know the regulate
regulations has made it really difficult
to survive and so you know this has been
a it's been a beautiful but very
difficult evolution and there's still a
lot of long ways to go yeah you try and
make an accelerator for companies that
are in a constantly shifting regulatory
market and also first-time entrepreneurs
trying to do that as well as like nuts
as well it's just trying to start a
business in general let alone one in an
emerging market that is like you said
also
occasionally deemed illegal by certain
you know certain places and so this is a
this is this is very challenging 20 of
them got through the Gateway and then it
was this passed along to other people to
operate no it actually ended up winding
down yeah my business partner and I
decided to go separate directions I
interestingly enough I was in the
process of continuing it on a new
fashioned raising a new fund this was
going to purely be focus on b2b kind of
the boring side of the supply chain I I
did find over three years like what we
really needed to do is add
sophistication and Trust to the supply
chain if we were truly going to reach
all those astronomic kind of valuations
that that people were quoting right the
hole in this US industry 100 billion by
2030 or or you know these billion dollar
brands that people are trying to build
the only way is gonna be achieved as if
we build scalability into the supply
chain ryan takeo ability and supply
chain yeah so insurance foreshadowing
kind of what I'm doing now it was you
know there was a few things that were
really garnering my interest you know as
biosynthesis of cannabinoids was super
interesting like I'm making minor
cannabinoids more prevalent by finding
alternative methods right that was
really cool stuff water solubility or
stability like making infused beverage
it's like I just known beverage is going
to be a huge category yeah I'm finding
the secret to do it and there's been a
lot of people dancing around it for
several years and you know I was I just
knew the people that were gonna do it
right there was gonna be a big
opportunity there yeah and there's
several others but you know in the
process of raising that fund I actually
had met Harold mmm who's our chief
scientist mm-hmm his entire career is in
surface chemistry so purely focusing on
the interaction between oil and water
yeah and learning how to control it make
it stable and scalable so he has a
phenomenal background PhD out of NYU and
I tossed him I was just he's you know he
he was the one who came to me at Gateway
he was very interested in joining the
industry
he's like how do I help all right look
you solved this problem you're perfectly
you know perfectly aligned for it you
know solve it and you'll have something
really worth pursuing yeah and he came
back to me probably about a month later
and he he did the thoroughness thing he
showed me this little vial he was like I
think I figured it out and I might show
me and he grabs a glass of water dumps
it in is just like disperses and it's
clear and I tasted it you know it was
fairly innocuous yeah and like I just
went straight tunnel vision at that
point like there could have been no one
else in the room it was actually like a
founder Institute event yeah though was
I was you know coaching startups on
picking on your company yeah he was
pitching me and I was like and and I
started asking questions and he had been
talking to some of the companies that
introduced him to everyone was already
trying to acquire him bring him in house
you know do all this stuff
I just asked someone like Harold do you
want to build a company and he said yes
and so I said you're not allowed to make
a business decision without me I just
need I want to make sure you know you
protect yourself he's a scientist you
know he needed some guidance and so I
started advising him early 2018 and then
by summer I was really encouraging him
to bring on a CEO and it was probably
about a month after I gave him that
advice that I kind of pitched myself to
him and so we launched the company and
got straight to work and so we've been
working hard at it for about a year now
yeah you know what we realize it's it's
way beyond just one vial it's way beyond
just creating a formula and scaling it
we take a real like you know we don't
believe in in the one size fits all you
know label for this particular
technology it's actually a very
complicated chemistry yeah
and so we approach each SKU with each
new customer completely differently and
we ask them you know what are you trying
to deliver to your consumer what's the
experience that you want them to have
the mouthfeel the taste and and beverage
has been super interesting like we could
literally infuse anything
that has water in it but we love
beverage because it is actually truly a
new experience it's a new way to absorb
the cannabinoids yeah can be very
complex it's perceived to be a lot
healthier since you're not smoking or
vaporizing so it's really exciting we've
seen 60 and 70 year old women trying
cannabis for the very first time having
a very beautiful experience and coming
back raving about it to all their
friends we've had people give us really
incredible testimonials on the medical
applications
like literally a woman living in pain
for 20 years with fibromyalgia you know
having one little vial 5 milligrams of
THC
all of a sudden sleeping through the
night painless you know it's just yeah
it's really special work you know we get
to do this every day
yes whoa it's really cool learning about
the Genesis story with Harold yeah yeah
it's cool how those things happen and
it's also great that that this more
complicated chemical surface chemistry
and just solubility was able to be
achieved because now it seems as though
the possibilities the combinatorics for
in infusing cannabis camp annoyed of all
sorts into beverages is unlimited
there's so many possibilities and
different people want different like you
said profiles of taste yeah they may
want different five milligrams or 20
milligrams they you know they there's so
many ways to pursue this so you may want
to do new as some it may want a brand uh
do you white white label yeah that's so
for this like event and stuff like that
or just like it's just like you get
crack you know you get the little you
send a little you know
voice to the device or soon thought
alone but then you know the little drone
or robots coming in and bring you the
little you know the little beverages
just I mean we get to work with so many
amazing people you know we've placed
ourselves right in the middle of the
supply chain we get to work with farmers
oil extractors you know people doing
like creating the most beautiful
full-spectrum life resins to CBD isolate
manufacturers in Colorado right all
those things flavor houses Co
manufacturers device makers we we've
been working with multiple people who
are trying to develop cold vaporizers so
basically just making a mist out of the
emulsion and so it's just a very high
bioavailability similar to a vaporizer
experience but with actually uh without
having to heat up the cannabinoids you
know self dosing systems where you can
put cartridges in each one has a
different cannabinoid and you just kind
of tell it the profile you want and it
creates the beverage that you're looking
for and this is the real exciting thing
for me is beverage is a great format to
really experiment with you know what is
commonly called the entourage effect hmm
but when people use the entourage effect
in cannabis they're usually talking
about the various cannabinoids
intervenes in the plant the entourage
can go well beyond that like how does
CBD and THC interact with caffeine or
l-theanine or a Shaquanda right it's
like really diving into kind of a
broader plant science and understanding
like the different types of experiences
we can create that's real combinatoric
they're too damn so you got to add in
all other types of dosages of yeah look
if caffeine's of teas of all different
types of plants that were extracts that
terpenes like you listed as well just
like wow it's endless so then what how
do you know how do I know what like you
know what I even like how can you cure
how to gain take like an experience and
then try and make like literally a
beverage for yeah yeah so for starters
right now we don't read some so right
now we're purely focused on the vehicle
right like we've created these um
amazing emulsion systems and anytime we
run into a problem with like an unstable
emulsion we really focus on solving it
so you put a traditional emulsion into a
red wine that's very heavy in
polyphenols you're gonna find
instability in the emulsion system we
have created emulsion systems that are
completely stable and high polyphenols
beverages
same with can liners their different can
liners have different reactions to
different systems we are making it a lot
more predictable to understand what
emulsion systems work in what cans and
what environments so that's the vehicle
work we can put anything that we want
inside those small vehicles and get them
delivered into your body right so okay
okay okay okay yeah so we were just on
like the massive like decade-long epic
and now we're on like baby step bringing
it back to here we're we're yeah we're
we're here so what emulsion system
mm-hmm okay so well that related to
solubility right so it's not true
solubility right so solubility is
actually when the molecules bind and you
have like a completely stable system
typically with sugar altar salt or sugar
and water or stir it up so yeah and
there are some technologies out there
that people are working on where you're
adding a sugar molecule or a salt
molecule to a THC molecule interesting
science very questionable about the
safety or scalability but it is one way
chemically to think about going about it
what we're actually doing is creating
these little vehicles that you can put
oil inside that are friendly with water
and it's more of a suspension system but
the the science that we do makes it so
that that completely homogenizes and
stays stable over time right so it's not
true solubility it's actually stable in
a suspension and if you you know what
you put into a bottle day one should be
the same as when you go to test it
should be the same as when the consumer
experiences it right so there's like a
matrix of molecules of water and
cannabis if you imagine these little
droplets that fall into the water
they're actually repelling each other
and that's what creates a stable
emulsion and keeps it homogenized right
so it's like if you imagine little
magnets and you drop them in with the
same poles you know they'd like bounce
off of each other and remain intact and
that's the goal you don't want to change
the droplet size over time and so in
maintaining the integrity of that it can
capsulation
the reason I kind of like dove back to
this is because this is the value that
we're creating right now are our
customers come to us and they say you
know we want to put THC CBD this full
spectrum spectrum extraction into a
beverage it's like okay we can help you
do that we can figure out the right
emulsion system the future is
understanding how to control the
experience right and so so right now
we're letting our customers be the
creative ones and we're emulsion system
is the hard science well that's why I
want to let's actually just take a
little more time on that so so what some
like what would be the like the girls
you know Kristen Price and Sarah Baker
right you know you have some very
serious rare diseases that people go
through rare health issues and so then
they need some sort of a full spectrum
have CBD for for for healing right and
maybe they wanted in the in a in a
beverage and it's a lot like 400
milligrams and the beverage or something
you have very high very high dose so
then what would a company like you do
how would you you said there's like an
emulsification yeah so there's a
multitude of things we can do you know
for starters because this is a medical
application you know it's probably less
important about what the packaging is
right it's like oh we can put this in a
glass tincture bottle you know we can I
don't think they're gonna put it into a
aluminum can so that immediately lets us
know okay we can use these emulsion
systems for that because the one of the
problems like that is this why you're
listening because the the because then
it would it would interplay with the
molecular aluminum that's right
and then that the can
there's an entire chemistry industry
around like what those what the liners
are inside the cans right so that's an
important facet then we get to like
first glass which we right yeah glass is
a lot more stable and then you know we
say okay you know how potent do we want
this like 400 milligrams that's quite a
bit so you're talking about taking a lot
of material and putting into a smaller
form factor maybe you know doesn't have
to be certain size and based on that
based on the desired taste and and
mouthfeel you know maybe it doesn't
matter maybe it's just about getting it
to hit as quickly as possible maybe like
all right we can make it super
bioavailable so that you feel it in less
than 10 minutes and that you know you
get that relief when you need it it's
gonna be a little bit bitter but man if
you're so if it's saving your life like
do you really care right bioavailability
yeah fast it exactly so all these
factors you know help us kind of align
the right emulsion system you know we've
made a thousand milligrams product
before we have a system for that it's
probably much different than a system we
use for time when the right product so
emulsion systems defer they based on do
we could be some dosage is based on
packaging they should they should yeah
yeah and that's kind of where we really
hang our hat right so you're a
multiplication scientist and so the
multiplication process is making the
cannabinoid work with the water yeah you
know and and and the interesting thing
about these emulsion systems is the one
that you create for a tap water you know
taste completely innocuous if you move
it to a different matrix and you taste
it it might all of a sudden have a
bitter note or you might have a more or
baisha snow so it's understanding that
it's not a one-size-fits-all right and
so it's just with that mentality you
know we could probably go back and and
look through our recipe book for all of
our different clients and have over you
know 80 different formulas that were
using well okay so then there's now with
with we're worth where this is currently
getting into does this seem like most of
ver Tosa is going
B or a lot of it is going to be its own
unique product line being distributed or
working with the different companies on
custom making what they yeah you know
true to my Northstar it's all about
facilitating other companies right so
the reason I want to focus on the
vehicle and create kind of this trusted
layer
you know ones where we go out and
procure the best materials to ensure
that we are working with the very best
ingredients the reason I really want to
do that is so we can get back to this
other 10-year vision of like really
creating great products and experiences
like if we take care of all this complex
stuff here it gives the product makers
the time and energy to think about you
know what other bioactive ingredients
can I add to this to really make a
synergistic product okay you know like
how do I take lavender oil and CBD and I
should Wanda to make a truly relaxing
product that's exciting stuff it is and
we're stimulating one yeah yeah and so
you know instead of making the supply
chain and and your access to it you're
differentiating feature like why not
make the true experience of the product
your differentiator okay this is really
cool so and it has a tremendous
foresight because what you guys do is
you see the 10-year and you see that the
10-year requires you to become the best
at the fundamental science of running
all the combinatorics so you literally
take ideas and you're enabling
creativity because you take the ideas
from the industry and then you actualize
those ideas which then give you
basically a catalog or a dictionary or
whatever you want to call it of a
database of methodologies that you are
using for all the different
combinatorics and then that way down the
line when it's all about experience I'm
jumping into this AR thing or I'm going
to machu picchu or i'm going to hang out
with my mom or you know any variety of
those things there and this is my
biometric state now so please make it
for that specific thing yeah yeah and in
a true experience and what I probably
need to talk to some of your guests
about is like how do we take all the
learning that we do
and really like make it exponential like
how do we have exponential learning on
like combining these different
ingredients and try to make it more
predictable about maximizing a certain
experience based on what we know from
each combination that we've already
tried right so this is where my my tech
background like starts to kind of work
its way back and like how do we take
this data and really learn from it and
make better medicines for the future and
make up for you know the hundred years
of prohibition that has a kind of
sequester at all this learning yeah so
there's a really interesting amount of
people now are starting to dive into
simulation software for these types of
purposes and you know the you go and you
look and try aim to reverse-engineer the
pieces that were put into the to the
final and to figure out what those
pieces were and then run again just one
experiment to experiment three
experiment run as many of those
experiments with slightly different
combinations as possible to find what
the ideal final target is given that
that all those profile variables that we
listed and maybe that actually is
something that I don't even know if
anyone is looking into cannabis
simulations it's it's very difficult I
think a lot of people have theorized on
it and I think that the true difficulty
is that it's two-sided right one side is
formulation the other side is biology so
like everyone's biology is completely
different especially when it comes to
cannabis because you're dealing with a
complex and a cannabinoid system that is
throughout your body and everyone's
receptors and everything have a
different sensitivity different
configuration and so somehow driving
towards a path where we have a better
way to understand our own biology and
calibrate medicines based on that that's
where you know the future of personal
medicine has been talked about for for
many years now and I think cannabis is a
incredible application of really like
delving into to the possibilities there
I like how you made it clear you know
you got this this formulation side and
you got this biology side you know
you've got a different then versus a
different or eva's a different alan and
these are just different biometrics that
are gonna compute your formulation in
slight variations and so if i want to
relax
or if he wants to relax or if you want
to relax that's three different formulas
very different yeah yeah because i mean
we all have different baselines right
and you're generally modulating from
whatever your own personal baseline is
and so you know people often in the
cannabis industry talk about indica
versus sativa you know sedative versus
uplifting and you know for me I don't
need anything that's uplifting I have
quite a bit of energy my mind works very
quickly so I prefer pretty much anytime
I consume something to have more of a
sedative effect and slow things down and
relax things and just slow the pace a
little bit right I get very anxious and
kind of ultra where like when I'm when I
consume a sativa and so you know
otherwise it might be completely
opposite for someone else it's just it's
making me realize how much harder
overdoses work it's cut out I mean
there's a reason we've been very you
know I've been a startup practitioner
for many years and in one word that we
always use is focus and yeah and so we
have been hell-bent on creating the best
delivery mechanism yeah to the point
where we're doing true pharmaceutical
bioavailability studies to understand
how the cannabinoids progressed through
the blood stream you know we're just
gonna keep hammering away on that for
quite some time you're gonna watch how
the canva noise go through the blood
stream into the body yeah it's I mean
it's important right you know different
cannabinoids metabolize in different
ways in the body how they're absorbed
different delivery mechanisms at the end
of the day what we're trying to do is
deliver an experience and and what that
you know another iteration of that is is
controlling consciousness
you know timing plays a big role where
it's absorbed how its absorbed what the
vehicle is made of you know we we have
even kind of some anecdotal evidence
that the the surfactants the the what's
in that kind of emulsion system can play
a role in how cannabinoids are absorbed
absorb so there's a lot to learn here
and in you know we don't ever pretend to
know everything we wear our limitations
on our sleeve but we're also eternal
students and we're just super curious
and ya know like you said running 12 you
know research experiments constantly in
the back lab Wow and were you guys base
right now Oakland Calif in Oakland yeah
and you guys got 11 people now we have
11 people on staff and you're looking to
hire we are which positions are you
looking to hire
all over so like science we haven't done
a whole lot of marketing and branding to
date so kind of just starting to start
hiring for that you know always looking
for more talented salespeople for
different categories we're doing work in
cosmetics and topicals now so that's a
whole nother beast well understanding
that supply chain and the different
nodes there so yeah it's um
yeah it's you know it's fun and we're
building company that you know more than
anything the north's are for the company
is building a great team because that's
when you know you can really achieve
special things yeah yeah that's what the
universe called you and Harold together
and now you guys are calling other
people together for action
it's pretty amazing we have this like
just ongoing kind of not a joke but it's
like we're always saying like how
serendipitously like everything is
happening for the company and we know
that can't last forever but we do know
that when that is happening in the
universe that you're on the right path
yeah and it has really truly felt like
that for the past year with the whole
team that's so cool yeah it's what a
blessing that is yeah you know it's a I
do a little bit of me is like you know I
feel like it's all the work that we put
put forth in the last you know 10 years
everything that we've been doing is kind
of like culminating into this
opportunity you laid the groundwork for
a long time on business acumen and focus
you know was a huge and now it's
tackling one of this is a great
interesting challenge in cannabis which
is gonna be such a readily available
thing beverages well you know I I talked
about in the beginning how I didn't
previously have a strong connection to
the plan and the true blessing is that
after I got into this industry I became
truly passionate about it and this
platform that I had of like speaking in
front of different crowds all around the
world
Rotech I just changed the conversation
and started educating about you know
children in pain not having access to
the medicine that can very easily you
know cure yes and so you know also
getting further in as soon as I entered
the industry like friends family
everyone start coming to me with
questions and you know I'm probably the
last person that should be giving
medical advice you know its blessing and
a curse you know I love helping my
family members but you know when when
someone has cancer or dealing with
chronic migraines like they should be
hearing it from their doctor and until
that becomes commonplace you know we
have a lot of work to do on the business
side because if there's anything we've
learned in the u.s. is that that you
know money talks right yeah and so if we
can build a great successful business
that is built with a very strong core
value that we can really help change the
world yeah many more questions for you
next time last question is what do you
think's the most beautiful thing in the
world oh man
I think it's this movement right now
like back people's movement back to the
planet understanding the power of the
earth and the plant and truly be
conscious about what people are
consuming and putting in their bodies I
think there's a big opportunity to kind
of you know leverage that to like I
don't know there's this happy marriage
when when capitalism is doing the right
thing
and it's like oh good money going to
good products creating good life for
people like I think you know there's a
lot of negativity out there in the world
right now but like if we see these
trends like people becoming more
open and more spiritual and leading to
conscious consumption like I think there
is a way to kind of just a better future
that's right then I'm so happy this
finally happened yeah thank you paint so
thanks for coming a pleasure program
yeah yeah and great work thank you Wow
awesome thanks everyone for tuning in
greatly appreciated we'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below in
the episode let us know what you're
thinking go check out the links to Ben's
work check out the links to vert osa
check out those links in the Bible oh
also two new West Summit I'll support
the artists the entrepreneurs the
organization's the leaders in your
communities around the world do you
believe in you can support simulation
our links are below to our show and also
go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much thank you for tuning
in and we will see you soon
finally that happened that was great man
thank you thank you so much yeah yeah
we'll definitely pick up more you know I
really want to dive deeper into you've
got your science and teach about that so
well we'll get more because that's where
the that's where the hard stuff to to
teach about is actually at
[Music]
you
[Music]